way.
Identify
has
remember
so many
However,
the natural disposition
of worship is that it is permitted or
prohibited
by default.
the natural state of customs,
things that people do to to to live,
walking, standing, sitting, running,
putting clothing on, eating, drinking,
speaking. It is by default permissible
or impermissible.
Permissible. Except what?
Except what Allah has outlined as being
prohibited.
It is the opposite with worship.
Correct?
With respect to worship,
all worship
in time, place and in how is permissible
or impermissible?
Impermissible without
direct instruction from Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. These are two opposites,
right?
And the worship of Allah,
you are not permitted to worship Allah
in this place, in this time, in this
way, unless he has instructed.
And with respect to things that are not
worship, right?
You are permitted to do all things
except that which Allah has what has
prohibited. Remember, think back to the
first
example that Allah gives us right after
saying
Allah says he is the one who has created
for you all for you all
everything that is in the earth.
Right after that he tells us the story
of Adam
and what did he instruct Adam
the nature of that admittance into
paradise was eat from anything that you
want as much as you want how you want,
when you want, where you want, except
for this tree, either a one tree or one
type of tree. It's unclear the verses.
The point is is that stay away from
that. So with respect to worship, we are
told what to do or what not to do.
With respect to worship,
we're told what to do or what not to do.
what to do
with respect to
customs, with respect to anything that
is not worship. We are told what to do
or what not to do.
What not to do.
This this is one of the most important
principles of all of Islamic f and law.
the nature of worship and the nature of
you know customs what we refer to as
customs. So
right
the
nature
The natural being, the disposition, the
default
of worship is that it is
not permissible unless Allah's messenger
has instructed it.
Everything,
all types of worship,
the statement, subhan Allah, who has
allowed us to say that? This is Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala taught to us very
specifically by the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
If the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
tells us
in the morning and in the evening
recite
okay in the morning every morning and
every evening recite
that's a sunnah. So, a person comes and
says, "I will recite it 2,000 times
every morning and every evening instead
of one time in the morning, one time in
the evening. No, 2,000 times in the
morning, 2,000 times in the evening.
That is permissible or impermissible."
What do we call that in Islam?
This is an innovation.
This is not just innovation, but it's
extremism,
right?
It's as if once that's not enough for
me, right? And there are things which
are generally permitted. But to specify
a time and place and occasion for this
thing and this exact way and this exact
number, that is not permissible. We have
to have evidence for that. Right? So the
natural position of worship is that it
is permissible or impermissible.
It is impermissible unless Allah allows
it.
Conversely,
the nature of customs, the nature of
human existence, the nature of our
relationship here in this earth, our
relationship to our surroundings and our
environment is that it is permissible or
impermissible.
Permissible. That's why Allah doesn't
tell us what to eat. It doesn't tell us
necessarily when to eat. doesn't tell us
what to wear, doesn't tell us when to
wear, doesn't tell us. He tells us what
not to eat. Meaning, eat everything and
these are the exceptions. He tells us
what not to wear. Wear everything except
these things here. He tells He may
suggest,
there are suggestions. That's different.
But we're speaking about permissible and
impermissible. Now when we come to
fasting,
fasting or prayer or any other type of
worship, if we were to say for instance,
I want to make Hajj, Hajj is made in
which month,
right? I want to make Hajj in.
I'm going to make Hajj in I'm going to
go and on the 9th of Sar I'm going to
stand on Araf and I'm going to do the
whole thing. But in not
is this permissible?
Huh? Would we just say that this is
invalid or would we say this is
positively haram?
Haram.
Why? This is exactly what the definition
of innovation is. Exactly.
Right. Person says, you know, Ramadan
doesn't really jive with my schedule.
I'm gonna fast during Shaan this year.
Right.
or I don't really the time of I'm
going to pray it two hours early or four
I could do 400 for from now on I'm going
to make 400 for is that permissible or
impermissible
haram right why the nature of worship is
that it is not permissible to approach
the king except in the way time place
that he has permitted subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
contrary to our existence in this world
we can exist however we want as long as
we don't cross the bounds of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala so when the author
tells us these are days which are
impermissible to fast
this means that it is haram to fast on
these days just it is waj to fast
on certain days. It is also what haram
to fast on certain days.
Same thing with salah. Just it is
obligatory to pray at certain times, it
is also what haram to pray at other
times, right? Etc. So I think we
understand. And so this chapter deals
with the days
in which it is impermissible to fast.
The first of that list is ali
the day the two days of the two two days
of right. So that is the first of
and that is the 10th of
those two days are the days of Eid right
those two days it is haram for a person
to fast during the that those two face.
[Silence]
in Bkari Muslim Abu
one of the freed slaves of Ibar. He
says that he celebrated the day of Eid
with Omar
and he heard Omar say where was this
likely said.
Imagine this. We have one of the
okay he says I was there for with
and I heard him say and then he mentions
the statement. He says these are two
days in which the messenger of Allaham
has prohibited fasting.
the day in which you all break your fast
from from Ramadan and the second day
when you all eat from your slaughtering.
So he's speaking about
when do we assume this happened? When
did he say this?
Think about it.
Omar
says this on the day of he's speaking to
a group of people. What was the
occasion?
Huh? Thebah the for what? The form
meaning incorrect. He's given the
he is speaking to the masses.
And he is saying these are two days.
These are two days in which the
messenger of Allah has prohibited be
fasting. The day in which you all you
all who speaks that unless you're
giving a huh what if we were just
talking two or three of us and I'm like
the day when you all break your fast
it's a bizarre way of speaking right
it's clear from the wording that this is
during autbah
this narration has been collected by
bkari Muslim.